[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you
is that our job numbers are so good that
the military has a hard time getting
people and I think really that's a
you're gonna have to be gonna see a big
spike I've already heard it a lot of
people calling in no place like our
military I think we showed that last
night we had great numbers this morning
I think it was two hundred and
twenty-four thousand jobs those were
really unexpectedly good and our country
continues to do really well really
really well so we're very happy about it
I think we're going to we're going to be
breaking records if we had a bed that
would lower interest rate would be like
a rocket ship
but with hangul out of interest and it's
unnecessary but we don't have a Fed that
knows what they're doing so it's one of
those little things but if we had a Fed
that was lower rate you would have a
rocket ship when Obama President Obama
was here he paid close to zero interest
rates I'm paying real interest and yet
our economy is much better than it's
ever been from election day were over
fifty percent increase and we
wiggity billion so we're doing very well
but last night was spectacular yes
[Music]
yeah I would love world for broadband
we're working on it and I would love to
have the Democrats come back and talk
about infrastructure talk about drug
pricing we're going to be announcing
something very shortly a favored nations
clause as you know for years and years
other nations
paid less for drugs than we do sometimes
by sixty seventy percent we're going to
be and we're working on it right now
we're working on a favorite nation
clause
where we pay whatever the lowest
nation's right there why should other
nations like Canada but why should other
nations pay much less than us they've
taken advantage of the system for a long
time Pharma that we're working on right
now a favored nations laws so that
whatever the lowest nation is anywhere
in the world or company but the lowest
nation or company then what happened
since we will pay that amount and that's
being worked on right now we're going to
do it in the form of an executive order
what thinking about doing that it's one
of the ways we have four or five ways we
can do it it's one of the ways that
we're thinking about doing it very
seriously we're doing well in the census
now he made a statement he wrote
something out the judge didn't like it I
have a lot of respect for Justice
Roberts but he didn't like it but he
didn't say come back essentially he said
come back that's what he was in so we'll
see what happens we can also add an
addition on so we can start the printing
now and maybe do an addendum after we
get a positive decision so we're working
in a lot of things including an
executive order I don't think I'm a
bully at all I just don't like making
being taken advantage of by other
countries by pharmaceutical companies by
all of the people that have taken
advantage of this country you look at
what Joe Biden is done with China
we've lost our church with China and now
China is dying to make a deal so and
we're taking by the way billions and
billions of dollars in tariffs are
coming in and China's paying for it not
our people
if you look at what we've done and if
you look at what week straight NAB we
Ike will it be Obama by Z mess with
straightening it out whether it's North
Korea you're going to end up in a war
with North Korea as you're just standing
there and now the relationship is a good
relationship we'll see what happens but
sure you're there you were going to end
up in a war with North Korea
I don't call them rapes I say they came
in illegally and we're bringing them out
legally these are people where we have
to pay freeze we've got through the
court system they'll be starting fairly
soon but I don't call and rage we're
removing people that have come in all of
these people over the years that have
come in illegally we are removing them
and bringing it back to their country
well I don't think of the descends of
that we're just celebrating the country
but there's nobody stronger there's
nobody that has a military anyway close
to ours as you know we spent seven
hundred billion dollars when I took over
the military
it was absolutely depleted we had old
flames with old jets we had bad I mean
this stuff that was tired now we have
the finest jets in the world the f-35
the FA T's the new one we have military
equipment the likes of which we've never
had building submarines building
aircraft carriers all made in the USA so
it's a double it's all made now I'm all
about jobs with great job numbers today
but when it comes to the military not
about jobs we have to have the greatest
in the world there's nobody that comes
close and our military now is just about
the top just about the best it's ever
been
there's nobody that comes close to the
power we have in our military what we
have and in fact if you look our nuclear
now is in great shape we've renovated as
we fix we're buying some new never want
to use it we never want to use it but we
have to be an efficient
that we have to be in a position but our
nuclear is in great shape our military
now is in great shape well I can just
tell you those people that you see a lot
of people in front of the White House
every one of them loved it I would
actually say and I want to go to give a
little appreciation the media generally
speaking loved it they loved the evening
we had a lot of rain I stood in the rain
too teleprompter went out so ad
yeah the teleprompter went out it kept
going on and then at the end it just
went out it went kaput so I could have
said that and actually right in the
middle of that sentence we went out and
that's not a good feeling when you're
standing in front of millions of
millions of people on television and I
don't know what the final count was but
that went all the way back to the
Washington Monument and I guess the rain
knocked out the teleprompter so but no
it's not that
I knew that speaks very well so I was
able to do without a teleprompter but
the teleprompter did go out and it was
actually hard to look at anyway because
it was rain all over it but despite the
rain that was just a fantastic evening I
think people really had it and I think a
lot of people you know is really a
recruitment situation a lot of people
are going to be joining our Army Navy
Air Force Marines
[Music]
what you campaigned on I'm gonna get
Trump I'm gonna get Trump's you never
knew me I never met her I don't know who
she is but she can her whole campaign
was that and that's illegal you're not
allowed to do that she knew nothing
about it she campaigned oh I'm gonna get
rough I'm gonna we have a hundred clips
and so do you and you can't do that our
system isn't about that our system isn't
about let's see if we can find something
we can't do that but her whole campaign
was I'm gonna get Trump I'm gonna get
him can't do that
you
collusion no obstruction after that it's
almost it's amazing you know what it
just it shows I'm the very honest guy
Oh China so we'll see what happens
they're talking to us they want to make
a deal but we had a deal and they broke
it
they broke the deal they seem too broken
it I think they had it to do again they
would because right now with great big
tariffs on we have a left floor to put
on if we watch vagina broken deal we are
talking film we'll see what happens
see what happens with Iran Iran has to
be very very careful
[Music]
you'll know in about two weeks very a
very interesting problem that they had
in New Hampshire I can tell you about it
but had nothing to do with White House
it was a problem up there and I won't go
into what the problem was but you'll see
in about a week
the southern border is being policed
very well by Mexico Mexico is doing far
more than the Democrats we all know it
because of tariffs but they've been
great
they put six thousand people to have
many of them there now of these southern
border their southern border on our
southern border which is the main border
that you think of they're going to have
anywhere between 16,000 and 21,000 trips
it's out of big effect you've only been
there for about a week where they
actually had the trip but it's had a
tremendous effect tremendous impact and
you'll see the numbers starting to come
in very well Guatemala is going to be
signing a fake third agreement we're
talking to Mexico but Mexico's really
doing a good job very very big but
here's the thing when people come in
illegally and then it's crowded and I've
seen some of those places and they are
running beautifully they please they're
good they do a great job they do a great
job they're proud us because the
Democrats will not give us any relief
from these loopholes we have loopholes
that are so bad
we have asylum that's so bad so these
places are many of them not all of them
but many of them they're incredible
they're really well run I'll tell you
what and I said it yesterday Border
Patrol is not trained to be doctors and
nurses and
janitor that's not what they claim to be
they claim to be Border Patrol and
that's what they're doing and they're
doing a phenomenal job because of the
country because we're doing so well as
the country we never we've never done
this less two days ago we hit the
highest rock market number we've ever
had in the history of Augustan
a country doing great unemployment very
low we just came out with two hundred
and twenty four thousand new jobs the
numbers are unbelievable and that's
bringing people up like they've never
come up Border Patrol and ice that's
done a great job now people are being
removed from the pension we're removing
them we're starting with the ms-13 we
take it out thousands of ms-13 again
but we've never had an unplug and the
reason they came up in treatment and
they come up
I think they do a great job with those
facilities but you know how it could be
taken care number-one-selling not to
come because it's illegal very unfair to
people that have been waiting on line
for seven or eight years and they're
about to be admitted and they studied
and they know the country and the
history of it and then a person comes in
walks in and all of a sudden they become
a citizen oh they're allowed to say so
thousands and thousands of people will
be legally removed from the country and
that process has started and we've
actually been doing that for well that I
don't know because I don't run it but I
would say this probably every club in
the United States has that because it
seems to be from what I understand a way
that people division but we've ended
whatever they did we have a very strict
rule and those rules are very strict but
it seems that every club practically in
the United States that's the way they
did this
[Music]
well I haven't seen it I will say this I
think that the Border Patrol completed
very very badly by different members of
Congress very very badly for the most
part they very respected by Congress but
members of
as exaggerated I'm going to throw people
at tough people they're not happy
I just spoke with the Attorney General
we have a number of different avenues we
could use all of them are one we're
doing very well in that issue with
spending 15 to 20 billion dollars on a
census we're doing everything we're
finding out everything about everybody
think of it 15 to 20 billion dollars and
you're not allowed to ask them are you a
citizen and by the way if you look at
the history of our country it's almost
always been that so we're look we're
fighting very hard against the system
that's a very difficult system but we'll
make a decision the Attorney General is
working on that right number one you
need it for the Congress you needed for
Congress for districting you needed for
appropriation where the funds going how
many people are there are they citizens
are they not citizens you need it
I thought Ivanka was amazing at the
cheap one and I'll tell you these
foreign leaders loved her and they think
she's great she's very smart and he's
done a great job he sacrificed a lot
Ivanka and Jared worked very hard as
they sacrificed a lot to be doing this
but they want to do it key vodka has
worked for almost 10 million job
training and going to companies and
getting them to hire people but the
people the foreign leaders really like
I'm
you know Obama had separation President
Obama in 2014 built the cells that you
always show in television they was built
by President Obama but he had separation
the one thing he didn't have is a good
economy so he didn't have the kind of
unplug that we're having we have a
tremendous onslaught of people who can
blame us they want to get in they want
to take advantage of the economy when
they have to come in
the book drop and Mexico a lot of people
but a dancer it's fine I didn't find
it's gonna be expanded for it definitely
there are many reasons if you do it but
I'm gonna we were surprised by that
decision citizenship has been on that
thing most of the time for many many
years so it's very shocking that after
spending fifteen billion dollars it's
not on no no tell by the NATO has taken
total advantage of him and President
Obama they took it we were paying for
almost all of NATO we're protecting
countries those countries have to
protect themselves with us they have to
make a contribution in my first year I
raised
over a hundred billion dollars from
those countries by you didn't know what
the hell he was doing and leave it as
President Obama NATO would take you this
Vantage up now they're paying they still
owe us a lot of money
Biden doesn't know about that he just
thinks stupidly
we do NATO is fine but they have to pay
their way the United States is not going
to get killed on trade with Europe
Europe kill Joe sun's rays which with
jay-z and Europe then kills us because
we defend Europe and we lose the Hutt's
amendment amount of money so we lose on
trade and the military President Obama
and Vice President Biden they didn't
have a clue they got taken advantage of
by China by a doe by every country they
did
[Music]
I don't know that I'll be able I just I
hope they do well I okay
and right now we have
we've got
back lot of good things happening and
has been no nuclear testing during
President Obama
and we're sending missiles right now
everything
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]